[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ومرحبا مشاهدينا الكرام الى فقره
وجها لوجه فيها نتوقف عند الدفاع الرئيس
الفرنسي عن قرار بلاده تقليس التاشيرات
الممنوحه لمواطنين دول المغاربيه مشيرا
الى ان هذه السياسه بدات تعطي ثمارها في
وقتنا طرحت فيه المفوضيه الاوروبيه خطه
جديده لمواجهه الهجره المتصاعده عبر
المتوسط من شمال افريقيا
لحقوق الانسان
الهجره السيده خديجه عنان اهلا بك ومرحبا
شكرا جزيلا لك على تلبيه هذه الدعوه
اهلا وسهلا شكرا على الاستضافه
هنا في الاستوديو الى جانبي السيد باسم
سالم المحامي والمستشار القانوني المختص
بقضايا الهجره سيد باسم سالم اهلا ومرحبا
شكرا جزيلا لك ايضا على تلبيه هذه الدعوه
مرحبا بكم قبل الحديث لو سمحتوا ما عن هذه
الخطه الاوروبيه الجديده اود ان ننطلق من
تشخيص الوضع حتى نفهم اسباب من خلال
المعطيات المتوفره اكثر من 90000 مهاجر
ولاجئ غالبيتهم من ليبيا وتونس وصلوا الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي هذا العام عن طريق البحر
المتوسط عبورا من شمال افريقيا الى
ايطاليا او مال في اي بزياده نسبتها 50%
على عام 2001 و20 وسؤال الذي نطرحه كيف
نفسر هذه الهجره
المتصاعده
خديجه عناني لعيبه رئيس الجمعيه المغربيه
لحقوق الانسان ومسؤوله ملف الهجره مرحبا
من جديد
اهلا وسهلا بكل تاكيد يعني هناك العديد من
الامور التي يمكن بها ان يفسر لارتفاع في
اعداد المهاجرين الذي لن سوف لن يتوقف رغم
كل الاجراءات التي يمكن ان تدخل نظرا لانه
نتحدث عن الدول المغاربيه ككل يعني هناك
واقع في ليبيا نعرفه جيدا في ليبيا ليست
هناك دوله ليست هناك ميليشيات يعني تتحكم
في البلاد نعرف الوضعيه الامنيه المتدهوره
نعرف الوضعيه الاقتصاديه
وبالتالي همم
الالاف لم نقل الملايين من المهاجرين همم
اللاجئين الان بعد يعني منذ 2011 وتدهور
الوضع الامني وهمم تدهور الوضع الاقتصادي
يعني هناك هجره متزايده عبر ليبيا
الوضع في تونس ليس كذلك هو وضع متردي انا
لا نعرف جيدا الواقع السياسي الذي تعيشه
تونس من جهه هناك نظام الاستبداد الذي
يقوده
قيس سعيد وهناك من جهه اخرى
بالالاف من الشباب والشابات
يعني عبور يعني هو اتخاذ كل المخاطر من
اجل الوصول الى امكنه يظنون انها امنه
هناك كذلك الوضع المتازم في المغرب
المستوى الاقتصادي على المستوى الحريات
والحقوق وكذلك هو الوضع في في الجزائر
يعني هذه البلدان تعرفون عن اقتصاديا
وامنيين وكذلك سياسيا متدهورا سيدفع
بالتالي بالالف الى ركوب كل المخاطر من
اجل الوصول الى الاتحاد الى دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي
همم فقط همم حتى اطرح لك نفس السؤال ضيفي
في الاسهل السيد باسم سالم المحامي
لمستشفى القانوني المختص بقضايا الهجره
نسبه المهاجرين القديمين من شمال افريقيا
عبر المتوسط زادت ب 50% هل همم كيف تفسر
انت همم هذا التزايد في وهذا الارتفاع في
نسبه المهاجرين غير نظمي الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه اكيد للمجتمعات المحيطه بالبحر
المتوسط ومنها مثل ما ان التونس ليبيا
وهلا دخل على الخط كمان على مصر احنا لما
نشوف اليوم ال 20 نقطه اللي كانت في
المفوضيه الاوروبيه عم تشمل انه هناك
تعزيزات او مخصصات سوف تصرف لنظام المصري
لحمايه الحدود بالاتفاق معه مثل ليبيا مثل
المغرب العربي وغيره من الدول اضافه الوضع
السياسي عنه السيد الفاضي لانه عم بتقول
انه الوضع في تونس هو في همم يعني يتراجع
الى الوراء ومتراجع ولا يمكن نصفه بربما
بالاستبداللات ذهبت اليه هلا اوروبا
لا ترغب مزيد من المهاجرين وهي حطت نظام
التاشيرات نزلتها للنصف حتى تحد نوعيه
المهاجرين للترغب بالوصول اليها المشكله
المهاجر الان الذي يرغب بالوصول الى
اوروبا هي حال اقتصاديه ان كان جيدا مثلا
في النموذج التونسي هل فعلا الوضع يوصف
بالاستبداد ما يفسر نسبه انا ما بعزيل
الحال الاستبداديه لكن هو عم بيكون سبب
انعكاس تتردد الاوضاع الاقتصاديه فبالتالي
المواطن التونسي العادي او الليبي اول
نينجا او حتى من المغرب
في مواجهه هذه الهجره المتصاعده المفوضيه
الاوروبيه كما تابعت كشفت عن خطه جديده
حتى وقرب الصوره لمشاهدين هي من 20 نقطه
لكبح جماح الهجره القادمه من الدول
المغاربيه على وجه الخصوص قوامها تعزيز
التعاون مع الدول المعنيه بما في ذلك
اتخاذ اجراءات ايمان انطلاق المهاجرين من
شمال افريقيا او رافع الانفاق الاوروبي
بين عام 2021 و220 الى 580 مليون يورو
لدعم دول شمال افريقيا والمساعده في تعزيز
النمو الاقتصادي وزياده فرص العمل في
المنطقه بعد يقولنا خطه ليست جديده ولكن
ما رايك انت في هذه الخط
وط الان بان الوسائل التي تتبعها الى حدود
الان هي غير ناجحه على اعتبار انه
الاهداف يعني
هو غير المعلنه الاتحاد الاوروبي وهو كبح
جناح يعني الهجره نحو الاتحاد الاوروبي
وطالما ان هناك
مستوى السياسي وعلى المستوى الاقتصادي
ستستمر هذه الهجره ما سيتغير هو الخطوره
التي ستواجه هذه الهجره من جاء هناك اغلاق
كل الابواب على الهجره او اغلاق اغلب
الابواب الهجره يعني النظاميه عبر القنوات
يعني النظاميه عبر الحصول على تاشيرات عبر
الحصول على امكانيات ل همم للذهاب الى
اوروبا وهناك يعني من جهه اخرى
دفع الدول الجنوب انها تلعب دورها دور
الدرك من اجل حمايه همم الحدود يعني
الجنوب
اتحاد الاوروبي عبر ما يسمى
بالدعم من اجل التنميه وللاسف يعني كل هذه
المستحقات الماليه التي تدفع واليات الدول
تذهب في اتجاه تعزيز الجانب الامني وجانب
مراقبه الحدود وبالتالي لا تستفيد منه
المناطق ولا تستفيد منه كذلك همم
المجموعات المهاجره الموجوده فوق هذه
الاراضي من يستفيد منه الجانب الامني
والتعزيز لوجيستيكي والتعزيز البشري على
مستوى الامني وهو تشديد المراقبه على
الحدود
تعددت الخطط
الاوروبيه السيد باسم سالم والاشكال همم
نفسه خمس 2800 مليون همم يورو مقترحه همم
هل هذه المقاربه شامله هل هي ناجعه فعلا
وهل تنجح في كبح جماح همم الهجره من دفع
حتى بالتنميه في الضفه الجنوبيه للمتوس
لان هذا هو الاشكال الحقيقيه التي تعتبر
ان المقاربه ما زالت همم امنيه لا اكثر
ولا اقل انا لا اتفق يعني الاتحاد
الاوروبي انا برايي عمل لعليه واكثر من
هالناحيه يعني هي الدول نفسها ما بتحترم
الاتفاقات اللي بتنقعد مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي نحنا شفنا اليه فعلا هي كانت
نجعه كثير شفنا انخفض العدد من القادمين
النشاط
باعاده هذا التجديد لانه تحولت كمعتقالات
للتعذيب او الاجار البشر وغيره لكن ليس
هناك خيار الاتحاد الاوروبي يعني لما
بيروح وزير العدل ال- ال- الفرنسي على
المغرب العربي وبيعمل اتفاقيه لعوده القصه
يعني القصه التي هم اهل وبرفض اجانب
المغاربي بالاعتراف بهؤلاء باهالي لما
بترفض سفارات الدول المغاربيه في فرنسا
بالاعتراف برعاياها وبعدم ترحيلهم فليس
هناك خيار للاتحاد الاوروبي او غيره من
الدول المغاربي الدول الدول الاوروبيه الا
ان الى هذا الخيار يعني هو اخر الحلول
وليس اولا الحلول وليس ولن ولن يكون اخر
هذه الحلول احنا بنحكي عنها يعني اتحاد
اوروبي لا يجد دائما خيارات باتفاقاته مع
الدول على هذه الدول ان تعترف برعاياها
لكي يتم ترحيل الذين لا يستحقون الهجره
فعلا في دول الاتحاد الاوروبي والاستقبال
عدد من الدول الاوروبيه بحاجه له من المهن
لاعلنت عنا من فتره فرنسا انه بحاجه فعلا
اللميها معينه لا تستقدمون لالى في راح
يكون الطريقه الشرعيه لاستقدام هؤلاء وليس
بطرق غير شرعيه احنا عم نشوف دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي تغصبه عدد كبير من المهاجرين نحن
ما بنقول المهاجرين هم ليسوا لاجئين يعني
لا يستحقون البقاء في دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي لان الاتحاد
لا نريد مهاجرين نحن نرحب باللاجئين فقط
لا نريد مهاجرين نرحب باللاجئين همم فقط
همم في ازاء كل ذلك وما ذهب اليه ضيفه حين
قال همم ذكر انه ثم عدم ايفاء بتعهدات همم
من جانب الدول تبيع اوروبا ترغب في ان
تكون لديها ايضا همم سيده خديجه عناني همم
سياسه حازمه بعد يصيبه انها متصلبه تجاه
الى هجره ابرز دليل على ذلك هو دفاع
الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون يوم همم
السبت همم في عطله نهايه الاسبوع عن قرار
بلاده تقليس هذه التاشيرات الممنوحه
لمواطنين الدول المغاربيه واشارته لان هذه
السياسه بدات فعلا تاتي اكلها وثمارها على
صعيد ترحيل المهاجرين غير المرغوبي فيهم
كيف تعقبين على ضيفي وما تعليقك على همم
مذهب اليه الرئيس الفرنسي
ابدا يعني بالنقطه الاخيره المتعلقه
بتصريحات ماكرون اذا كان يعني بانه قد اتت
اكلها في ان تجعل من مواطن ومواطنات الدول
المغاربيه رهائن
لصراع السياسي بين الدول المغاربيه وبين
فرنسا فقد نجح في ذلك بالفعل اصبحنا رهائن
لاننا لا يمكن لنا حريه التنقل الى الدول
الاوروبيه همم بشكل اصبح شبه مستحيل لا
لزياره الاقارب ولا
للذهاب للدراسه ولا للعمل رغم الحصول
البعض على عقود عمل ولا للذهب من اجل فقط
السياحه في دول الاتحاد الاوروبي لقد نجح
في ذلك اذا كان هذا ما يعني لان الحكومات
غير معنيه بحريه التنقل الوزراء يتنقل
هناك ما يشاء ورؤساء الحكومات يتنقلون كما
يشاؤون المشكل يبقى بالنسبه لمواطنه
ومواطنات هذه الدول الذين يحرمون من حقهم
في التنقل كما هو منصوص عليه في اتفاقيه
الدوليه لحقوق الانسان والتي من المفروض
ان الدول الاوروبيه التي يجب ان تدافع
عليها اذا كانت بالفعل دول ديمقراطيه
وتدعي انها ديمقراطيه من جهه اخرى انما
يتحدث
يريدون المهندسين والاطباء
والباحثين والاطر العليا ولكن لا يريدون
باقي المهاجرين وهذا في حد ذاته مشكل خطير
لانه يقوم على تمييز حقيقي لانه يتم
استنزاف الدول المغاربيه الان من القطن
التي تعلمت في المدارس المدارس
وبالتالي يتم الان احتضان بكل فرح في حين
انه يتم همم يعني همم
المهاجرين او على الاقل انهم يعيشون في
اسود الحالات من جاء اخرى اريد فقط ان
اتفاعل فيما يخص القاصرين همم يمكن لضيفك
الكريم ان ياتي هنا الى المغرب وان يرى
اعداد الاطفال الموجودين في الشوارع لا مش
جيدا انه لو كان بالفعل يتوفرون على اسر
لديها الحد الادنى من العيش الكريم ما
كانوا لي همم ليتركوا عائلاتهم ويذهبون
الى اوروبا لو كانت بالفعل تتوفر لهم
الدوله الحمايه المفروض ان توفر لهم ماذا
ذهبوا الى هذه الى تلك الدول الاوروبيه من
جهه اخرى الوضع في ليبيا انا في الحقيقه
اجد صعوبه في فهم كيف يتحدثون عن حكومه في
ليبيا يتم عقد معها الاتفاقيات والكل يعرف
انه هناك في ليبيا ليست هناك حكومه هناك
حكومات وهناك ميليشيات وهناك وضع همم سيء
للغايه في همم سجون
يتواجد فيها العديد من المهاجرين والذين
من المفروض انه بينهم الالاف من طالب
همم المهاجرين الذين ياتون من ليبيا وهم
من طالب اللجوء لان الوضعيه السياسيه في
ليبيا كلنا نعرفها جيدا الذين ياتون من
افريقيا جنوب الصحراء نعرف الوضعيه ونعرف
النزاعات والحروب التي يعيشون
على السياسه الاوروبيه للهجره وعلى
السياسه الفرنسيه ايضا وعلى سياسه الضغط
الفرنسيه على الحكومات المغاربيه التي
ترفض
التعاون او الايفاء بالتزاماتها كما كنت
تتحدث لاستعاده رعايها غير المرغوب فيهم
في فرنسا هل هذه السياسه سياسه الضغط هذه
هل هي صائبه هل تحترم حقوق الانسان فعلا
وحريه والحق حتى في التنقل كما قالت ضيفتي
وهل همم تؤتي فعلا اكلها كما يقول الرئيس
الفرنسي انا اتفق مع الضيف الكريم انه
ميثاق الامم المتحد الى اضمن انطلاقه
حريته تنقل بين الدول لجميع الدول ولكن كل
دوله تستطيع تطبيق هذا الاتفاق يعني
بيتناسب من مصلحه يعني هذه الاتفاقيات او
هذه الفيز الموضوع هي ليست همم وضعت الغد
هي موضوع منذ همم 50 سنه حتى من الاول من
حق الدوله اللي بتضع شروط استقبال احد
رعايه الدول على اراضيه وغير هناك
اتفاقيات بين الدول
تقنن هذا الموضوع لا اكثر ولا اقل هلا
الاتحاد الاوروبي ما يقوم به هو انسان او
غير انساني لم يعد يعنى الاتحاد الاوروبي
بهذا الاتحاد الاوروبي يعنى بالناخب دافع
الضرائب يلي عم يدفع الضرائب عم بشوفها عم
بتروح على مشاكل ومشاريع لا تقعد تشدي
نفعا في المجتمعات الفرنسيه وغيره عم شوف
مواطن فرنسي ليس عنده قدره الشرائيه
فبالتالي هو المواطن فرنسي اخر همه ماذا
يحصل في الدول المجاوره انسانيا هو عليه
ان يكون قدر الامكان الانسانيه باستقبال
الناس
بحاجه الى وضع انسان وهي الدول عفوا
الرعايه القادمين من دول في حرب او دول
دول
سوف يستقبل بما يتفق مع المراعي المصالح
الدوليه وحقوق الانسان وهؤلاء الناس لكن
ليس عليه ان يستقبل كل المهاجرين
المغاربيه من خلال عمليه الهجره
الانتقائيه التي ترغب سيد سياسي الاوروبيه
سياسه كل دوله هي مصلحه هذه الدوله يعني
بغض النظر هي ضد تضر في مجتمعات اخرى ولكن
ليس يعني ليس زم فرنسا انها تستقبل اصحاب
الكفاءات او حتى الدراسات او من الاطباء
والمهندسين اي مشكله الدوري نفسه انه ما
عم بتحاول فعلا انه ترعى هؤلاء بعد ما
انصرفت عليهم وعلمتهم
الدول المغاربيه فبالتحديد ليس مشكله
فرنسا فرنسا الحاج سيكون من المغرب العربي
وغيره من الدول يعني لا يقتصرون على
المغرب العربي بالعكس هؤلاء هم يشكلونه
همم القدره الشرائيه ممكن ان تكون ترسل
الاموال الى المغرب العربي مع الاقتصاد في
المغرب العربي
لم يعد هناك خيار اخر امام الرئيس مكرون
وغيره من السياسات الاتحاد الاوروبي لكن
هناك يعني
انها همم هي غايات سياسيه او غير سياسي
ولكن اجدد يعني صار هي نافعه فعليا يعني
همم بطريقه كثير جيده حاليا احنا فعلا في
تراجع في هذا الموضوع لكن سياسينا وغير
سياسيا اكيد هو يهم الموضوع السياسي كون
انه الناخب يتجه الى اليمين اكثر فاكثر
طيب السيده خديجه عناني ضيفي تحدث بشكل
صريح عن ربما دوافع فرنسا ودول الاوروبيه
عامه من خلال همم
خطط الهجره او السياسات الهجره ولكن اود
ان اسالك في اخر سؤال اطرحه عليك وعلى
ضيفه ما مدى المسؤوليه التي تقع على عاتقه
الدول المغربيه كان يتحدث عنها ضيف حتى في
ملف الاعتناء بكفاءاتها في ملف الهجره
ايضا غير النظاميه خاصه مع بعض الاتهامات
التي تطلها من استعمال ملف الهجره احيانا
كثيره كورقد سياسي بمعنى ان هي ما انت
احيانا تاخذ بعض الاطراف او ابنائها
رهينه او مساله حتى غلطه طرف عن عمليه
الهجره غير اني راميه والتي تؤدي الى
الموت المحتوم او حتى وصف بابتزاز اوروبا
ماليا خاصه ان هذه الاموال وانت نفسيه
نفسك قلتها في بعض الاحيان تستخدم لعسكره
الحدود ولا تقدم الحلول الف
للمهاجرين حلول التنميه التي ربما تقنعهم
بالبقاء حيث هم وربما تفتح لديهم افاق همم
افضل همم للحياه السيده خديجه عناني في
دقيقه لو سمحتوا اختم مع ضيفي بنفس السؤال
هناك كذلك استخدام هذا الملف من جميع
الاطراف من اجل الضغط السياسي نحن نعرف
انه المغرب او الدول دول دول المغاربيه
خاصه تونس وليبيا وتونس والمغرب والجزائر
يستخدمون ملف الهجره اا في محاوله للحصول
على
تموينات من دول الاتحاد الاوروبي هذا
نعرفه جيدا لكن الاتحاد الاوروبي عندما
همم
الاموال هذه الدول لا تهمه يعني وضعيه
المهاجرين في همم على الرغم من انه يرى
امي عينيه انه هناك احتياجات لحقوق
المهاجرين في هذه الدول ما يهمه ان تتوقف
هذه الهجره باي ثمن على حساب همم يعني
حياه وعلى الحساب سلامتها هؤلاء المهاجرين
همم الان انه رغم الوفيات العديده التي
نراها رغم ان المهاجرين اصبحوا يعني ورقه
يتقادفها من جهه السياسات هذه البلدان
وكذلك شبكات للتجاره في البشر والاتجار في
المهاجرين همم نرى كذلك بان يعرفون جيدا
ان الدول المغاربيه
للاسف رغم انها همم يعني همم سياسيا ليس
هناك يعني حمايه لحقوق المواطنين وكذلك
لحقوق المهاجرين عندما يذهب يعني اطار او
مهندس او طبيب من المغرب الى
اوروبا او كذلك شباب يعني كثيرين هم فقط
ليس فقط من اجل همم المساله الاقتصاديه
فقط ولكن كذلك لانه هناك مشكله انه مستوى
الحقوق والحريات لانه هناك همم
غير موجود يعني حريه معتقد هناك من يغادر
بسبب حريه
المعلوماتيه الفرديه بسبب حريه
الراي والاقتصاديه هناك كذلك الوضع يعني
الحقوق المتردفات البلدان الذي يدفع
بالشباب واذا كان من ما يمكن ان تقدم دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي لهاته الدول وان تدفع
بالفعل الى ان تصبح دول ديمقراطيه من اجل
ان تحتضن ابناءها هذا هو الحل بالنسبه
اليه ضيفتي مع تحول المتوسط الى مقبره
وكلمه ختم لك باختصار شديد
بشكل كبير بهذا الشعبيه بتستخدم ملف
الهجره الاتحاد
فبالتالي تونس بتقول انا كمان بدي احصل
على هاي الاتفاقيه وغير من الدول وهل مجره
الجزائر
يعني فعلا الضحيه هم اللي يعرفون في هذا
البحر هم فعلا بامس الحاجه اليسرى الاتحاد
الاوروبي لكن الاتحاد الاوروبي بحسب
قوانينه حاليا لم يقعد لم يقعد بقدرته على
استقبال المزيد هو قلت لك مره ثانيه
يستقبل اللاجئين انا اتفق مع كل ما هو
ملاحق حريه الراي اا يطالب بالحريه
بالتحديد حسب يمكن ان يستوعبها لكن
الاتحاد اوروبي ليس بامكانه الاستيعاب
وبالتالي مثل يعني الناخب الاوروبي اصبح
الان له اليد الكبرى والمسؤوليه تقع ضفتي
المتوسط كل شكرا جزيل لكم على تلبيه هذه
الدعوه وعلى هذه الحلقه عبر الاقمار
الصناعيه من الرباط السيده خديجه عناني
نائبه رئيس الجمعيه المغربيه لحقوق
الانسان المسؤوله ملف الهجره كلها شكرا
جزيلا لك سيدتي على تربيه دعواتنا وفي
الاستوديو كل الشكر جزيلا لك السيد باسم
سالم المحامي مستشار القانوني المختص
بقضايا الهجره كنت ما معنا في فقره وجهها
عنق